I need everybody who's listening right
now to really go to stock ax and eBay
and see what's going on a lot of people
when they get educated that they can
make more money in sports cards than
they can and cryptocurrency and cannabis
will run towards your game
I mean $150,000 on LeBron James lucky
cards in four months they come from a
thousand of four thousand dollars wanna
be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge and is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you to you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the number one investment
strategy right now for Gary Vaynerchuk
okay let's kick it off with tip number
one do your research
sports cards are exploding Jim I need
everybody who's listening right now to
really go to stock ex and eBay and see
what's going on I've been investing in
sports cards for eighteen months last
April and May and June I bought 50
LeBron rookies and now they grade them
you send them to a company they say if
it's a perfect ten a nine and eight
about 50 / 50 ends at $1,050 a piece now
they're selling for four thousand a
piece Wow Gary give me a brief primer
not knowing a lot about this if I want
you to buy told me what do I do you go
to Google and you search sports cards
you know why are sports cards going up
like you type in questions on Google
then you go to ebay completed items and
you type in athletes Lamar Jackson
rookie card and you hit you hit search
and then you get completed items and you
can see for the last two three months
how much they've gone for let me give
you the comp there I wanted to do it and
I sucked I missed made a huge mistake I
didn't take action because I liked
Lamar's game I didn't think he was gonna
do what he did this year but Lamar
Ricky's in perfect tens were thirty five
dollars going into the season now
they're three hundred last year I did it
with giannis I bought him at 180
they went there at 800 now here's so you
go to ebay and stock acts and you look
at the prices and you look at completed
auctions and that gives you you spend
four to ten hours on that looking up
athletes most of the cards your
listeners and I grew up with aren't
worth anything because it was during the
junk wax zero where they made a million
of these now they make limited numbers
of them and the vintage created stuff is
going great but there's three reasons 45
year olds are now having SEP now have 7
year olds so they're reliving their
childhood gambling you can buy a $200
pack of cards right now that's how much
they can be now Jim 200 for one pack but
you can pull $150,000 Luka or Xion
so gambling and then finally you know
sports cards have a lot more volume than
sneakers so we have an entire generation
of teenagers who are now in their 20s
that grew up flipping Easy's and Jordans
who now if they think that Lamar
Jackson's gonna be the guy they go out
and buy five hundred two thousand four
thousand Lamar rookies and make $100,000
in nine months tip number two take risks
you should start investing in sports
cars
I'm not kidding listen to me I'm telling
you no [ __ ] I need it I mean
$150,000 on LeBron James loci cards at 4
months they've done from a thousand to
four thousand dollars CJ would call him
texted me tonight yeah it's made two
hundred thousand dollars in a month
listen I'm being dead serious I put over
a million dollars into sports cards over
over startups and over real estate and
it how much do we make a mean ba picked
off a like 7x a little bran I mean I've
just been getting into a little bit like
on French ibotta LeBron three weeks ago
$2,400 it's $4,000 if the labor labor
labor
LeBron rookie you're too neat siakam
last year before the run call it this
time last year it's gone up 80 X 80 X
you could have spent 200,000 and made 80
X I bought eight hundred be honest were
keycards last year that at $180 there
are a thousand I'm telling you right now
it's like sneakers all the sneaker kids
you can't get enough off whites you
can't get enough Travis Scott you're
kicking enough Easy's but if you're
right about you know who I bought a ton
of for pennies Devonte Graham point
guard in Charlotte we're like if you
know sports you can make a fortune and I
mean a lot
three things one 45 year olds like me
the biggest Arab sports cards was 1986
to 1992 ever 80 those boys now have sons
that are 6 7 8 so that always happens
that's how toys work every 20 years
number 2 gambling gambling you can buy a
3 now packs a pack of cards can be $200
now yeah and you know what you can find
in there $150,000 ayah you can pull
$150,000 Luka rookie cards from last
year and a pack of cards gamble number 3
sneakers you can't get enough of these
if you know this is the next hot sneaker
you can't buy enough dunks off-white
Colette you can't get enough it's over
the Internet limited edition so what
happened is all those kids that made a
ton of money that's 13 14 15 16 year
olds because they got all their friends
from high school to stand in line at a
sneaker store and buy 50 pairs that
games over so they've taken their
attention to sports cards because if you
were right about Luka Donna I bought
Lucas for 38 dollars last year because
draymond Green told me he's like a real
player and I trust frame out cuz he's
you know he's dream he's always like
everybody was like this guy can play
another $400 I could have bought I
bought 100 I could've bought 10,000 I
could have made millions of dollars
you're gonna love this Who am I I think
you get answerís because I bought sixty
one of them the other day what's the one
card I'm buying the most stuff
the number one card I'm buying I can't
wait to tell you hakeem olajuwon rookie
guard it's $250
nothing my belief is that Africa and
next 3040 years is gonna be the number
one new continent like Asia and when
that happens
hakeem olajuwon rookie cards are gonna
be the demand for coming this is 30
years it's a long time but I still it
believe it I'm buying so much hakeem
olajuwon it's crazy vision this is our
part that's right okay but what's more
to what's fun to have a vision that's
right so for you whether it's Jordan or
magic or Kareem fine but then on top of
that so there's art long-term 30 years
and then there's and this is why you
have such a big advantage there's
Thursday night in Cleveland and you're
watching Collin Sexton and you're like
why is he that I'm so good right like
there's a two side there's high I mean
if you if you're right about cognate
Collin Sexton if you're right about him
if you're right about your guy parents
like you get those right you're talking
20 50 100 X so you gamble a little here
and you buy but I'm telling you it's
asking he watches what I do know
investing because everything's
overpriced because everyone's I got a
startup there's like I've seen this
cycle of like I mean you're not writing
any checks like you like you were four
or five years ago right what you say
about
yeah investor wise so I'm gonna give you
the advice I'm taking I'm not investing
anybody startups cuz almost everybody's
got a business everything's everything's
face to $59 how do you do it
meanwhile this is black and white and I
and I like it and know it all so if you
want to have more confidence motivation
and self-love check out my 254 series
they're free the links to join are in
the description below
I really think mindset is everything and
so you've got a really desiring any
positive bit about basic negative things
in a success world please understand
that success is happiness not net
dollars in my ability to only be
comfortable in massive chaos has been my
biggest asset as an entrepreneur like I
would never take a note like that scares
the piss out of me what these three
people are doing right now tip number
three don't miss opportunities now I
don't know if you saw the news but it
just popped up on TMZ right here
[Music]
$900,000 for the LeBron Jordan one of
one upper deck
I'm telling you the culture of sports
cards you know first of all
first it was the kicks the kicks kids
are coming the dads that have kids that
are 7/8 or comin and the gambling is
coming we put all four hundred thousand
dollars ion in a pack of cards sports
card culture is hearings but try to tell
you it's gonna keep happening if you
love sports betting if you love fantasy
sports if you think you know something
about rookie or if you want to bet
long-term and buy classics the time is
now the culture is happening don't miss
them
yeah tip number four be patient I
currently run two businesses however
there's one business that I'm currently
struggling with that includes sports
cards okay no supports cards might maybe
like big in the US and Canada however
here in the UAE I don't think anyone
really collapsed nose yeah okay so I've
been trying to talk to my friends and
send some companies about there and
educate them about it however I'm not
really successful in building a
community for the niche
how long have you tried to build the
community for the niche like two months
okay you know where I'm going right
I mean first of all you've got a
obviously look of proper football cards
for this niche right there's a much
better chance
like maybe basketball definitely not
football or baseball like this is gonna
be a football market a proper football
market it will happen here if it
continues to go the way it's going
because people are making a fortune on
it and a lot of people when they get
educated that they can make more money
in sports cards than they can and
cryptocurrency and cannabis will run
towards your game you just need to stay
patient you just told me that you're
struggling after trying to do something
for eight weeks and tip number five the
last one before a very special bonus tip
is get lucky that's just hunt a little
bit I mean I really want to pull it you
know I want this this was I was like you
know what I want to hunt with Gary for a
moment and if there's a possibility to
no it's not even no it's not no grip no
grip ease so Juan Gonzalez this was this
was on olerude Gonzalez I got a Mookie
Wilson big shout out to Mookie leer
Mookie Wilson was my guy and it's also
weird as a bluejay not a met that it is
that you're you're a you're a Jets and
Yankee fan
which is a weird combo it's a weird
combo but not for some it's a weird
combo because means is Right mess but as
you know I pulled up Juan Gonzalez did
you I literally call me the best card
and pull did you I pulled a Juan
Gonzalez pulls the best bang literally
said this was the one and got it first
Pappy okay now I've got a special bonus
tip from Gary on how to have fun that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
question of the day I want to know what
do you think about sports cards are you
into it are you a buyer are you gonna go
research more let me know put it down
the comments below and if you made it
this far in a video and you promise you
commit to take action after watching it
give me a hash tag believe down the
comments as well I want to celebrate you
in one of these packs for example I
could pull right now I know it's 105
thousand packs and do a lot of right I'm
gonna try to pull a card of myself I
wanted to be documented the first time I
ever pull a card of me in it this is
super insane
there it is
Jose Ramirez geremy's top I cannot
believe I just pulled it was so awesome
how insane is this I am literally on a
baseball card are you kidding me this is
an insane that was so cool that was so
cool that was awesome I'm so glad we cut
my face has to be Evan thank you so much
for having a couple seconds and being
able to tell the believe nation a little
bit about empathy wines it means a lot
to me that you take this valuable real
estate and and time on your channel to
give me some love means a lot it's just
good karma points and so you're just
you're awesome thank you believe nation
if you're into wine at all go to empathy
wines calm my whole careers work was
poured into producing a wine that
rivaled forty to sixty dollar wine for
twenty bucks a bottle I'm just super
excited about this subscription-based
wine business
you can order three six or twelve
bottles in subscription form Rose a
white red
if you cook if you search on Instagram
or Twitter you will be blown away people
are lure like I don't even like Gary Vee
but the lines good super proud of the
effort thanks Evan for the time wishing
you guys all happy and healthy
if you want 50 more rules from Gary
Vaynerchuk check out the video read
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there my ability to only be comfortable
in massive chaos has been my biggest
asset as an entrepreneur like I would
never take a note